The Kurds are the largest ethnic minority
in the world who do not have a state of their own.
There are approximately 30 million Kurds in Syria, Iraq, Iran and Turkey.
They have now become very important actors
not only in Iraq, but also in the Syrian civil
war and in Turkey.
The Kurdish people are separate, they are
linguistically different, they are culturally different
from the dominant group in each one of these countries, which are Arab, Turkish, and Persian.
The Kurdish people are mostly Muslims, they are moderate, they are secular, they are pro-Western.
If you ask every Kurd, they have this dream of having a greater Kurdistan.
And yet, because they were divided at the
end of the First World War when the
Ottoman Empire collapsed and the borders were drawn at the time by both colonial powers and by
the Turks, and because they were a minority in each of these countries they never succeeded
in getting their own state.
However, the Kurds never accepted the conditions
in which the international community or history put them and always rebelled.
But because they rebelled over the years they were always a threat to the stability of all these countries.
The Kurdish question is for the Kurds, this
long-term quest to establish their own independence
from the countries around them. They, to date, have not succeeded in doing this because
of the geopolitics in the region.
In none of these countries, when you look
at the history, Kurdish cultural or political
identity was recognized. Brutal means of suppression
and oppression were deployed to forcibly assimilate the Kurds.
Conditions on the ground are changing everywhere.
The Kurds have now become very important actors thanks to three major developments.
One is the Iraqi Kurds have achieved a great deal of autonomy in Iraq and it is autonomy
that is recognized internationally, it is
recognized by Baghdad.
In Syria, we now see that the Syrian Kurds
have succeeded in fighting off the Islamic
state, that has taken over large chunks of
territory both in Syria and Iraq.
And the PKK, the Turkish-Kurdish insurgent group, are now in the process of historic
negotiations with the Turkish government about some kind of resolution to the Turkish-Kurdish
civil war which started in 1984 and has been quite ferocious, 40,000 people died, mostly Kurds.
The issue of the Kurds, and the Iraqi Kurds
in particular, has become a very serious consideration for US foreign policy because they played
a really prominent role in helping create
the post-Saddam Iraq.
And now, we see that the Kurds have been a partner in trans-national issues,
particularly in the fight against the Islamic State.
The Kurds of Northern Iraq have been essentially
autonomous from Baghdad from the time the first Gulf War ended in 1991, and the United
States and allies sought to protect the three provinces that make up the Kurdistan Regional
Government, and has provided an opportunity for the Kurds to develop their own society.
Since the fall of Saddam Hussein at the hands of American forces, there has been this effort
to create a unified federal Iraq, but giving
the Kurds a special status as a region within Iraq.
It is difficult for us to keep waiting for an uncertain future,
waiting in vain for implementation of the constitution and our rights.
That's why Kurds have no choice but to think of another path, toward self-determination.
The Islamic State, has erased the modern Middle East borders in a way that no other
state or non-state actor or force has been able to do since the collapse of the Ottoman Empire.
And for the first time, because of ISIS
the central government in Syria and Iraq,
primarily, are very, very weak to prevent
the Kurds from achieving what they want.
When the Syrians started the uprising against
president Bashar al-Assad's regime, Assad turned a blind eye to the Kurds, so the Kurds
exploited that opportunity. They declared
self rule in northern Syria.
When the Islamic State swept through Syria, the Syrian Kurds put up a resistance, which
essentially got the Americans bombing the ISIS positions.
In Turkey the Kurdistan Workers' Party, which is a terrorist organization, had been fighting
against the Turkish state since the mid 1980s seeking their own independent state or at
least autonomy from the Turkish state. But since 2002 when Erdogan and others came to
power, there has been, some opening to the Kurds.
Erdogan has sought a negotiated solution to the problem of the PKK.
"This normalization process will be to the
benefit of all of our citizens, Turkish, Kurdish, and other ethnicities."
"I invite the PKK to attend an extraordinary
congress in spring to make the strategic and historic decision to abandon the armed struggle."
There are dilemmas for all of the Kurds as
a result of what's happening.
The major policy dilemma is related to the Iraqi Kurds. Do they stay or do they go?
Clearly the population very much wants independence. The fear in Ankara, the fear from the Syrian leadership,
the fear from the Iranian leadership, is that an independent Kurdistan would result in Kurds
in these other countries seeking to emulate that.
What's complicating for U.S. strategic and
political interest is there's a very delicate
balance here both with Baghdad and with Ankara.
The Turks are still opposed to the idea of an independent Kurdish state.
However, they have come to be key economic partners for
the Kurds, and that has made things easier for the United States and Europe, and others,
in dealing with the Kurds as legitimate and important political actors.
And in Baghdad, particularly because of this tenuous sharing of political power and sharing
of resources that Baghdad and the Kurds have never really been able to resolve definitively,
it's been difficult for the United States
to support the Kurds in the robust fashion
the Kurds feel they deserve.
ISIS has required the United States to get
more deeply involved with the Kurds because the peshmerga are essentially the ground forces
in the fight against the Islamic State.
You obviously have the fragmentation of Syria.
You have the fragmentation of Iraq going on. Ultimately, Washington may be confronted with
a situation where it would be in the interests of the United States to be more supportive
of at least Iraqi Kurdish independence.
The Kurds are closer. They're not close, but they're
closer to becoming independent, as the situation around them deteriorates.